So what do we have to have in our cache
in order to support a miss-under-miss
operation?
Before the cache would simply
block when it has a miss and
not do anything until the miss comes.
So it doesn't really need
much support for that.
With miss-under-miss we have a miss but
accesses keep coming to the cache.
If there hits, we handle them normally
by just finding those blocks and
returning to the processor.
If there are misses, we have to do more.
Now we need to have the so called
Miss Status Handling Registers or MSHRs.
What they do is they remember
what we requested from memory.
So they keep information about
the misses that we currently have in
progress.
When we have a miss, we have to check
the MSHRs to see if there is any match.
Basically if we have a miss, we want to
know whether it's a new miss or
something that we didn't find in
the cache but it has already been
ordered from memory because of
a previous access that was a miss.
So if it's not a match, that means
it's a miss to a different block.
In that case, we allocate a new MSHR.
In the MSHR, we remember which
instruction in the processor to wake up
when the data comes back.
And that's it.
If there is a match, that means that
we try to find data from a block and
that block had a previous miss that
was already sent to memory but
didn't come back yet.
So really, if we did things one at
a time this would not be a miss.
So we call this a miss and this is
sometimes called half-miss, because
this is a true miss, that we would have,
even if we did blocking caches.
This is a miss that would be a hit if
we did blocking, but because we allowed
the processor to check the cache,
before the previous misses came back,
some of the new accesses are now not
finding the data in the cache but
the data is already on the way
back to the processor.
Now because the request for
this block has already been sent to
memory, we shouldn't send it again.
Instead, we simply add that
instruction to the MSHR and that's it.
When the data finally
comes back from memory,
we find the MSHR that
corresponds to that request, and
we wake up all the instructions
that were added to this MSHR.
The first one, and all of the subsequent
ones that also wanted the data.
Keep in mind that the miss and
the half-miss to the same block, need
not necessarily be to the same word.
Actually it's quite common that, for
example, you access the first word and
then very soon you access
the second word in a block.
The first word had a miss,
the second word will have a half-miss.
And after waking up the instructions,
we release the MSHR so
it can be used by another miss.
So how many MSHRs do we want to have?
It turns out there is a huge
benefit even if you only have two,
so it can handle two different
blocks in progress at the same time.
Four is even better, and
there are benefits to be gained even
if you have 16 or even 32 MSHRs.
So we want to have a few
tens of MSHRs if we can.
This is because memory
latencies are relatively long.
So if we can keep sending requests
to memory during that time,
we can be achieving the memory
level parallelism of 16 or even 32.
Cutting down dramatically
on what the overall performance
penalty of cache misses ends up being.